it's Friday the 13th and we've got a new
stranger things trailer to dissect plus
our top picks for Halloween movies you
can stream now sup witches
happy Friday the 13th and welcome to a
special school key themed episode of the
daily denne now how fitting that on the
date considered unlucky and Western
superstition stranger things is sending
us back to the upside down with the
final trailer for season 2 coincidence
I think not the latest trailer is filled
with so many nostalgic 80s references
and help me break down the easter eggs
you might have missed what help that's
awesome yeah I am wearing the jumper
brothers have said that their show and
especially the second season is inspired
by classic horror and sci-fi films from
the 80s as we know it takes place around
homi 1984 that's the same year Friday
the 13th the Nightmare on Elm Street
gremlins and at children of the corn hit
theaters speaking of children of the
corn
poor Louisville buyers he was trapped
and upside down in the first season and
now he looks more apt up than ever
Oh check out these other references
that's 11 rocking Sigourney Weaver curls
from alien and in front of a TV like the
poltergeist there's this aerial shot
serving some shining guys and this one
is a bit on the nose but the kids are
dressed up as Ghostbuster okay but
there's also dust and looking like you
straight out of the Sandlot not a scary
movie but also a classic and how's this
for nostalgia this season they also
added 80's heartthrob Sean Astin of The
Goonies and Paul Reiser from aliens
now the unworldly entities aren't the
only things the folks of Hawkins are
running from Baker Montgomery has also
joined the cast this season as the new
kid in town Billy the duffer brothers
have said that this character is similar
to Jack Nicholson's Jack Torrence from
The Shining we really wanted a human
villain this you know year I mean we
always talk about Stephen King but he
always has the human villains are often
scarier than the monsters and so we
wanted to introduce a human character
who
we'll scare the crap out I'm already
shook like is it October 27 yet is when
the second season of stranger things
will be available on Netflix can't come
soon enough and we've got a full
breakdown of all the references and I'm
working on a hot area that's gonna be up
on ET online.com today I love it thank
you so much Ashley you look great in my
shirt
are you guys from 80s horror classics -
one of my favorite 90s
slashers I know what you did last summer
if you can believe it turns 20 the 90s
classic found jennifer Love Hewitt
Freddie Prinze jr. Sarah Michelle Gellar
and Ryan philippi on the run from a
crazed fisherman from the past it was a
movie that as et found out turned
jennifer Love Hewitt's life upside down
in between us it's exciting it's um it's
kind of overwhelming you don't really
know what to say but it's um it's kind
of like a rollercoaster ride it's early
the teen horror flick became a fast hit
grossing over 70 million dollars at the
box office I just knew that I was I was
like one of the luckiest actresses in
the world first of all to work with the
amazing cast that I could to work with I
mean Sarah Freddy Ryan all of them are
amazing being something that Kevin
Williamson wrote you know you kind of
you couldn't dream of anything better
other than just getting to work with
them so the other stuff just seemed
really like a bonus when et caught up
with Hugh at the premiere she was
officially declared Hollywood's newest
scream queen
they'll that speaking of good we asked
the community which scary movies we
should watch tonight and you guys are
definitely in the Halloween mood because
we've got some goodies the new it movie
might have broken box-office records for
a horror movie but the art 2016 says the
original it still gives them chills
mommies suggest scream which by the way
is one of my faves up there with I know
what you did last summer and Regina
she's schooling us all I wrote Friday
the 13th duh duh are you guys three more
scary movies you can stream right now
the babysitter is now available on
Netflix and it looks batshit not gonna
live but also really funny so why not
but if you're in for a classic the
original Amityville Horror supposedly
based on a true story is so freakin
scary and you can stream that now on
whoo if you're brave enough I'm also
gonna recommend cabin fever this one is
not for the faint at heart
it's literally skin crawling and also up
on who if you're in the mood for some
Eli Roth ridiculousness
so there you guys have it go get your
spooky movie on we've got 18 days until
Halloween so plenty of time to binge and
I also want to know what do you guys
gonna be for Halloween I'm already
planning my Frida Kahlo costume so I
want to hear what you guys are planning
out there all right be safe and we'll
see you guys on Monday I love Halloween
game